for Senator Cortez Mastro one of many
high-profile Nevada Democrats
spearheading the push to be number one
today I asked her about the switch to
primaries and being among the first
states to select presidential candidates
whether President Biden should run for
reelection and what she wants to work on
the Senate having won re-election why
should Nevada be the first primary State
I think Nevada is crucial
and whether we are now first or second I
think it is important that we are there
in these presidential races if we are
talking about and what I believe is and
what I know for my last election is as
Democrats just in general we needed to
be talking to people in the working
class we need to be talking to these
families and talking about what matters
to them and focused and fighting for
them Nevada is a perfect state to get
that for 2024 would you support
President Biden running for reelection
or do you want to see some new people in
there yeah no it President Biden runs
for reelection I will support him I mean
let me just say this the last two years
under President Biden gave us the
bipartisan infrastructure package the
American Rescue plan the chips and
science act the inflation reduction act
these are all things that I was able to
get around in the state and talk to him
about how we have benefited and thought
for our Working Families here in Nevada
should he run that's his decision to
make there's so many
topics to tackle right budget
immigration
price gouging
what are you honing in on we need to do
more to address the mental health needs
in Nevada and across this country and
bring more resources to fill in the gaps
not just on the crisis mode of it when
that first call is made but short term
and long term and that's going to be my
focus and I've said this also we have so
many dreamers in our community DACA is
still an important issue I'm not giving
up I've just been in conversations about
how we continue to push the envelope
push the administration but also work
with some of my colleagues including my
Republican colleagues to say let's do
right what did uh Adam laxalt say to you
when he called and conceded
I will tell you uh not going to disclose
I think it's personal but he did make
the call not only did he make the call
he followed up with a statement and
that's more than I received in the last
election when I ran for Senate
so remember the changes today from the
DNC affect only the Democratic races but
state law puts all the presidential
primaries regardless of party on
February 6 2024 remember we're not
talking about this February we're
talking about next February the one in
2024 and by the way the Super Bowl here
in Las Vegas just days later that same
week so it's going to be a big one now
that we're in the number two spot